[Music]
how about could you get in transfer
Federal Reserve funds to some place you
know we like not being in jail
we'd say no we wouldn't do that if we
really wanted to and really had to okay
yes because if you make it easy enough
for yourself or somebody else to use it
you make it vulnerable do you think
there is a system can be designed that
would be foolproof that we could use for
defense the goal should be to make it
very difficult to get in many of the
problems that are out there that that
contribute to this lack of security
are are extremely simple buffer
overflows are spotable in Source Code by
a first year college computer programmer